hey guys my name is Jess it is in 16th
of January and we are back with GameSpot
news and naturally I have a bunch of
Nintendo switching years to kick us off
first up Nintendo of America president
Reggie fils-aime a has said that the
Nintendo switch is a home console at
heart resume told wide that the switch
is a home console that you can take with
you on the go and isn't intended to
replace the 3ds he added in our view the
Nintendo 3ds and the Nintendo switch are
going to live side by side you're going
to be meeting different price points
you're going to be meeting different
types of consumers they're going to
coexist just fine we've done this before
managing two different systems he also
said that Nintendo intend to ensure
there's a steady stream of games
releasing for the switch as the
publisher said that we you had loved
gaps between releases regardless things
seemed to be going pretty well as
retailer gamestop announced today that
it has sold through its first batch of
Nintendo's switch stuck next up called
Judi infinite warfare has dropped to the
number two sales but in the UK as Grand
Theft Auto 5 has regained its leads
snails Molitor chart track has revealed
that for the week ending January 14
rockstars open-world action game is back
on top rounding out the rest of the top
5 off FIFA 17 battlefield 1 and 4 to
Horizon 3 it's worth noting that these
stats do not include digital sales data
GTA 5 is now assault over 6 million
units in the UK alone and was reportedly
the fourth most played game on Steam in
2016
finally Nintendo has confirmed that the
switch will supports old micro SDXC
memory cards it sounds like you'll have
plenty of options when it comes to
expandable memory for the new console as
Nintendo told Game Informer which is
compatible with the SDXC standard which
supports up to 2 terabyte nor to the two
terabyte card and not yet on the market
but the system will support them when
they are currently the largest commonly
available SDXC card has a capacity of
512 gigabytes but it appears the console
will support both the one terabyte and
two terabyte cards when they become
available unless you purchase most of
your games digitally however your online
Klee to need a lot of extra space as
nintendo's which doesn't require it's
games to install to system memory in the
same way that ps4 and Xbox one games do
the switch includes 32 gigabytes of
built-in storage let me know down in
that comment section what you cared
about today head to GameSpot for stories
on minecraft and Mad Max and I will see
you again tomorrow